situé sur les hauteurs de saint-andré en
bordure de la rivière du mât le site de
dioré s'étend sur 2 152 hectares dont
104 sont classés en espace naturel
sensible une forêt de moyenne altitude
où les espèces endémiques végétales et
animales soupe réservés si on monte un
peu dans les hauteurs on peut découvrir
le site et naissent avec toutes ces
espèces endémiques et indigènes au
niveau de la flore on peut dire qu'on a
le full sa patte marron les biscuits
n'ont rien us boîte le bois de corail le
bois de piment au niveau de la faune on
n'allait pas pendre le fait les humains
barboni cas les lézards verts des eaux
et on a aussi tout ce qui est technique
d'oiseaux la vierge pendant les
week-ends nature les visiteurs profitent
de la beauté du site mais aussi des
explications apportées par les guides
sentir les fragrances des fleurs
découvrir les espèces en voie de
disparition
cette balade est un véritable échange
entre les guident les visiteurs et la
nature ici c'est tronçon regardez qu'est
ce que je fais ici
toujours avec cette explication très
imagé qu'est ce que ça vous ça vous dit
quoi officiers de police et une pattes
de poule ça ça fait penser à une patte
de poule
d'où le nom liane pas de poule et on
utilise en tant que peuple en mai c'est
une plante médicinale utilisée pour la
fièvre le refroidissement cantona la
grippe
voilà et au bout du sentier la forêt se
découvre enfin c'est un point de vue
exceptionnel qui se dévoile devant nous
le cirque de salazie vue du piton de
dioré on a un beau panorama sur le début
de salazie on voit aussi la casquette
blanche le piton d'anchaing et si c'est
bien découvert on peut voir aussi le
piton des neiges
c'est toujours très sympathique on est
bien un gros panier on apprend des
choses on est dans la nature enfin c
c'est vraiment un grand grand plaisir la
forêt est magnifique
on découvre beaucoup de l'espèce
végétale et puis les oiseaux les oiseaux
la vierge et etc tech
on a vu plus être un vol de l'oiseau la
vierge ces mâles et femelles c'était
très lourd et puis après on arrive au
point de vue sur salazie qui est
magnifique
surnommé le poumon vert de l'est le site
de dioré renferme un véritable
patrimoine naturel à la fois par sa
diversité mais aussi par ses paysages
uniques
il faudra compter 2h30 de marche pour
découvrir toutes ces richesses
quant à nous la balade se termine par un
atelier de tressage de vacoa va quoi oui
fait partie du patrimoine réunionnais
puisque nous en fait ils utilisaient ça
pour déjà pour
seloger puisque les toits des maisons
était avec le vacoa ensuite pour
transporter tout ce qui était les cros
marchandises est aussi bien pour la
nourriture comme tous lancés ils
mangeaient le chou dubois quoi